with skins looking twice as filthy in
CS2 players have been going Buck Wild
trying to unbox some of the game's most
coveted items so much money please
please okay
oh how about so much oh my God case
unboxing has always been a popular hobby
but things are getting a bit out of
control don't believe me well according
to case tracker players open nearly 40
million cases in March alone no that's a
lot of damage if a standard key costs
250 that means valve made at least 100
million dollars last month and that's
not including the cost of actual cases
[Music]
the craziest part is this might only be
the beginning the last record for case
unboxings was earlier this year in
February and things only seem to be
trending up